the proof of work contestants mechanism
uses a lot of energy
what's the response to that criticism of
bitcoin yes because it's worth it
okay the airplane uses a lot more energy
than a kayak you know when you're going
to cross the atlantic next time what are
you going to take a kayak that is
environmentally friendly according to
this insane definition or are you going
to take an airplane that consumes a lot
of energy so the cost benefit analysis
here
essentially you have to consider both
the cost and the benefit
exactly and i think it's an astonishing
testament to just how far backward
people's scientific and technological
thinking has devolved to the point where
we think of energy consumption as a bad
thing i think it's just and in the fiat
standard i discussed in the whole
hysteria around energy and i think it's
uh it's a product of fiat
inflation because it's a way of trying
to covering up the fact that energy
fuels that are reliable and necessary
for the current world are becoming more
and more expensive because of inflation
and so governments are always looking
for excuses for why you should not be
using those things and so they promote
all kinds of stupid pseudosciences to
tell you about
why these things are bad but really you
know all technology is well not all but
the vast majority of technological
innovations involve
economizing on human time and judgment
and replacing it with machines with
reliable machines that spend a lot of
energy so
that's what a telephone does instead of
having to send somebody across the world
to tell somebody something else or send
a letter a telephone allows you to
do it the car is like that you could
walk but a car consumes a lot more
energy but it allows you to travel much
faster and safer and more reliably an
airplane is like that modern
telecommunication
human prosperity is an increase in the
consumption of energy and i think it is
it is an absolutely criminal thing and i
genuinely mean the word criminal
to
portray energy consumption as a bad
thing because it is truly depriving
people of the chance to live a life that
makes life better you know in this sense
it's truly criminal to tell poor
countries that they should not consume
the same energy sources that are being
used in rich countries that on which our
modern infrastructure and modern life
relies
that's what life is you know if you
reduce the consumption of energy in the
us
to the levels that you have in poor
countries today the us would become
desperately poor a lot of people would
die cities would collapse the quality of
life would decrease significantly a high
quality of life often requires
given the current technology high
expenditure yeah and i should be clear
you know it's not a quality of life in
the sense many people think of this as
oh yeah well you know
taking needless
flights for vacations no no these are
the these are the cherries on top of the
cake but the substance of the cake and
the real benefits of energy is the fact
that
children premature babies survive in
countries that have reliable 24-hour
cheap electricity if your child is born
premature that you put it in an
incubator put him in an incubator or her
they're highly likely to survive if you
don't have 24-hour electricity
that child is not going to make it and
you see it you know that level of energy
consumption per capita is highly
correlated not just to income but also
to health outcomes to infant mortality
to all of the things that you care about
and um bitcoin is just another
technology it does consume a lot more
energy than central banks a lot of
bitcoiners like to
take in a cop out of this by saying well
you know central banks consume money and
atms consume energy and i think if you
calculate how much central banks and
banks consume i think it's a rounding
error next to
what bitcoin consumes i think bitcoin is
just maybe not a rounding error but it's
still bitcoin i think is going to
consume a lot more and that's a good
thing you know what's humbling is to
look because even just looking into this
forces me to look at the energy
expenditures for many of the things we
take for granted obviously computers and
the digital
our digital lives
i just uh bitcoin becomes a rounding
error
relative to how much energy spent on all
the computers in our world but also like
things like home appliances microwaves
and yeah hair dryers and stuff yeah
yeah i mean this is that's being
hilarious it's like oh these things that
are just part of our modern life
they're either the same order at least
the same order of magnitude as bitcoin
and they seem like trivial parts of life
yeah and this is the thing all the
people that complain about bitcoin's
energy consumption i presume they use
washing machines now why should their
desire for clean and dry
clothes um
to get to consume energy and
i mean i i used to live in lebanon
lebanon had hyperinflation i
escaped from hyperinflation i escaped i
it prevented
my life could have been ruined by
hyperinflation and the reason that it
wasn't ruined is because i have bitcoin
so
i don't know am i allowed to swear on
your podcast yes please so [ __ ] your
washing machine
uh
given a choice between my washing
machine and my bitcoin i'll choose
bitcoin i it's it's a technology that
has been that has already saved my life
and i think it's gonna save the lives of
many many many many more people so
um
but of course i don't have to choose
between um
my bitcoin and my washing machine
because um this is you know we're just
constantly consuming more energy and
we're gonna continue to consume more
energy in this world
and that's just what progress is and a
small remark so in principle that i
don't think this is a problem but the
other thing about bitcoin where it is
different from washing machines
bitcoin is truly unique in this it's the
only thing whose energy consumption
can be produced absolutely anywhere your
washing machine needs to be in your
house where you live and you live in a
city surrounded by 10 million people and
they all have their washing machines and
they're all connected to the grid and
they generally tend to do their laundry
around the same time and so you have to
put the load of the washing machine on
the grid at the same time there's needs
to be one power plant and all the
infrastructure needs to work at the same
time and the electricity is pretty
expensive because
it's being done in a place with high
demand bitcoin is does not need to buy
electricity from
places where it has high demand because
it can buy electricity from anywhere
this is what's truly mind-blowing about
it you can buy you know what you need to
the electricity that you need for mining
can be done anywhere so you can
mine you know you can have a
waterfall in the north of canada
300 miles away from any population
center there's water falling there's
energy you can put a hydroelectric dam
there and then you can use that energy
to operate the miners and then the
miners just need a satellite internet
connection and effectively you're
selling that energy that is isolated to
the grid
and because of the way that bitcoin
functions because of the difficulty
adjustment
the only profitable miners are the ones
who can get cheap electricity
basically if you're mining at grid cost
if you're mining at around the average
electricity price in the world is around
14 cents if you're mining at 14 cents in
bitcoin you're most likely not going to
make it
if you're running your miners at 14
cents because everybody could mine at 14
cents and so what happens is if
everybody's mining at 14 cents
14 cents stops being profitable and then
only the people mining at a lower price
are profitable so that's why bitcoin
mining is not competing with your
washing machine this is this is the
absurd thing about this kind of energy
scarcity um
viewpoint where oh no it's a catastrophe
bitcoin is taking all the electricity as
if the electricity is just one fixed buy
that we all have to share and fight over
and this is that's how i keep making fun
of these stupid headlines they put out
where bitcoin's consuming more
electricity than portugal all right well
maybe we should shut down portugal then
what the hell has portugal giving us
like obviously it's not it's it's not he
doesn't mean that i've gotten so much
criticism for saying krishna and
cristiano ronaldo is not in the top five
um uh i apologize
i love portugal that's another
discussion we should get into something
because you posted a few soccer things
i'm not yeah i realize how passionate
people are about this listen it was a
joke all right he does not love people
in the top five yeah i love portugal
and even though i'm a liverpool fan i
still respect cristiano ronaldo a lot in
fact i hold a very unpopular opinion
where i think christiano and all those
the greatest football player ever number
one over pele maradona messi better than
messi yes he's been doing it for 20
years at the top nobody's ever done that
he's won everything everywhere
everywhere he goes at the top at the
champions league
really strong argument to be made for
him and messi's never done anything
outside of barcelona that's the thing so
you appreciate performance long term
versus the genius of the actual play on
the field
i mean the geniuses ronaldo is the top
scorer of all time he says the geniuses
in the scoring not the actual dance of
the of the play the creativity well i
mean i don't know messi has been
absolutely mediocre since he's left
barcelona this is strong
words what two goals in psg season this
year they're out of the champions league
what about muhammad salla you've you've
posted oh yeah is he he's boy is he
climbing up to be i think i think he
should win the ballon d'or this year he
probably should have won it last year as
well he's been absolutely outstanding
but um
i mean just people are so crazy about
messi they keep giving him equities he
hasn't deserved i think messi the last
couple of ballon d'ors that he got
i mean he's a great player and
everything but uh no he didn't he did
not deserve it last year
we can agree to disagree
there's
you're a boston fan or a messy fan i
would say
no i'm not i wouldn't say i'm a barsa
fan but bars a fan because of messi and
i just i i think it's like there's
certain things
um
so when i was growing up in the in
soviet union russia i remember maradona
he was the first person
i saw that i was like oh wow this could
be um
this is greatness in sport not just
football and sport right and for some
reason i mean it's something about like
diego armando
like the way they were commentating the
the genius of his play the the mix of
ego and again the performance but being
able to carry a team on his shoulders
that i just fell in love with whatever
he represented and then by that
argentina and then messi i saw when he
was like 16-17 when he was just like
right in the early days and when he's
when you first see a person and you see
the genius and you notice that and then
it turns out to be actually a great
player for some reason you're invested
you're
emotionally invested you're um i don't
know so you kind of just fall in love
and then uh you get you pick sides i
mean that's the thing about football
part of the fun things about
uh football soccer is like
you pick a guy you pick a team
and [ __ ] everyone else and you just have
fun talking [ __ ] i mean there's part of
it you know it's great it's great
because uh i i think you know obviously
it's very stupid thing to do but i think
if you don't do it in football you're
gonna do it in real life elsewhere
that's right that's why it's very good
like that's it i you know instead of
hating people for their religion and for
their skin color
hate them because they support
manchester united exactly
so you're a liverpool fan yes yes
hardcore long term
uh
but yeah so to go back to the original
point on portugal um
yeah energy bitcoin is not competing
with uh portugal because bitcoin is
buying energy from places where we can't
buy it because all the places where we
can buy energy for our washing machines
we're bidding up the price
enough to make it and non-viable for
bitcoin that's why you know they'll
you'll see those headlines about bitcoin
consuming more energy than portugal well
if you look at portugal i mean they've
got giant power plants in portugal
they've got millions of people and
they've got enormous amounts of
infrastructure where are all these
infrastructure for bitcoin mining you
don't see it in the cities it's all
isolated it's all out away from the
cities or it's connected to grids that
have serious overcapacity so bitcoin is
not out there buying the expensive
energy taking energy away from uh
people who can't afford it
it's out there buying its own energy
because it doesn't need to buy the
expensive energy that people really need
you